es ist ein geschäft mit dem tod
zumindest die fernsehmoderatorin miriam
pielhau bei einem wirkungslosen
krebsmittel aufgesessen und hatte alle
hoffnungen darauf gesetzt
diese hoffnung war trügerisch sie hatte
studien über die wirksamkeit in
fachmagazinen im internet gefunden alles
wirkte total seriös das geschäft mit
diesen nicht wissenschaftlichen studien
ist ein millionengeschäft und miriam
pielhau eines ihrer opfer klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
es war mir ein bisschen peinlich im
fahrradgeschäft sprach mich eine frau an
und meinte da für uns kennen
miriam pielhau schaltete ich im
nachhinein ich hatte sie wegen ihrer
kurzen haaren nicht erkannt das war kurz
vor ihrem tod hier in berlin
damals sagt sie sind noch in interviews
dass sie geheilt sei wenige wochen
später am 12 juli 2016 starb sie dann
das hat mich ziemlich vom hocker gehauen
das jetzt allerdings ans tageslicht
gekommen ist das ist dann richtig
verstörend miriam pielhau ist fake
studien zu einem medikament aufgesetzten
sie dachte dass sie gcf geheilt hätte
doch die studien zur wirkung waren
unwissenschaftlich und konnten die
wirkung gar nicht nachweisen
so haben es jetzt recherchen von ndr wdr
und süddeutscher zeitung ergeben
erschienen sind die studien zum beispiel
im verlags 1 publications was viele
wissenschaftler wissenschaftlerin nicht
wissen hier werden die publikationen
nicht peer reviewed das heißt es gucken
keine fachwissenschaftler und fast fach
wissenschaftlerinnen über die studien-
und bewerten sie sondern das findet
einfach nicht statt sie werden ungeprüft
veröffentlicht die schuldigen so geht
sie macht hätten es nie in eine seriöse
publikation geschafft dort sehen
experten experten über die studien- und
wären in diesem fall wohl schnell über
schwere methodische mängel gestolpert
für laien aber auch für fachleute ist
das aber nicht auf den ersten blick
erkennt dich also ist nicht auf den
ersten blick klar dass diese magazine
nicht seriös sind und so hat dieses
geschäftsgebaren dramatische folgen
erstens es werden wissenschaftliche
studien veröffentlicht die keinen gehalt
haben zweitens wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen veröffentlichen in
diesem umfeld auch seriöse
wissenschaftliche studien ohne es zu
ahnen die feldstudien bekommen so eine
hohe glaubwürdigkeit drittens und das
ist wohl das schlimmste aus den falschen
studien wird zum teil sogar in seriösen
studien zitiert so findet die fake
wissenschaft ihrem weg in die seriöse
wissenschaft absolut katastrophal und
die ausmaße sind unglaublich nach den
recherchen von wdr ndr und süddeutscher
zeitung haben alleine in deutschland
5000 wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen in solchen fällen
zahlen veröffentlicht sie setzen ihre
studien und ihrer wissenschaftlichkeit
damit jetzt erheblichen zweifeln aus und
das sind nicht nur irgendwelche
assistentinnen oder assistentin in der
zweiten reihe auch renommierte
professoren und professorinnen sind
darauf reingefallen sie finden jetzt
ihre studien neben unwissenschaftlichen
papieren von klimaskeptikern und studien
her von herstellern dubioser medikamente
gegen krebs autismus und parken sondern
auch wir werden hier stärker auf die
quellen achten und nicht mehr jede
zehnte studio schokolade isst gesund ist
nicht gesund ist gesund und so weiter
sofort veröffentlichen also wenn ihr
kein video zu seriösen studien mehr hier
verpassen wollt dann hättet mich bei
whatsapp dann geht er die kaputte avaloq
sie auf youtube und verpasst kein video
mehr
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
persönlich von jedem upload und zwar
noch vor allen anderen täglich
garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und
am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal
kriegs um social media abonnieren da
gibt es das neueste aus der social media
welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
genau die glocke vergessen hier geht es
weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken fake
news in der wissenschaft ja da geht es
um eine feldstudie dies sogar in die
seriöse times geschafft hatte
bis dann